it isn't obvious often whether you own
something or it owns you
and and i don't mean that in a flippant
sense oh i wouldn't at all recently i
was invested in you know people doing
cryptocurrency now it's like invisible i
don't even know what it is you know but
it's
people are excited by it and i started
to notice
those markets on this crypto thing and
uh and i didn't mean to interrupt you
dr no please go ahead um thanks um
so but i noticed like i'd wake up in the
middle of the night and i would check
this thing and
finally i realized like whatever monies
i'm gonna
possibly make in this portal this
gambling portal of cryptocurrency
um which no judgment on it i don't know
enough about it to really judge it but
i'm spending like important time
checking it i was just i realized i
became a slave to it like
and so i just sold it all i don't want
i just it did i in in my heart and in my
chest it didn't feel good having that
distraction to check all the time
about what was going on with this money
it just felt like it owned me
and um and i immediately decided you
know what i just don't want to be owned
by this
maybe something else but just not this
you know
right and was it specifically the worry
about it that was bothering you or what
what do you think
triggered or or alerted you to the fact
that that pursuit wasn't for you
that's a great question i think it was
um
i couldn't control myself this is the
truth i couldn't control myself from
checking it
and so the only alternative i had was to
eliminate it
because i was really having trouble and
it doesn't fully answer your question
but i was just having trouble stop
checking it so i just said i have to get
rid of it well it answers it to some
degree you found
um to your surprise see this is partly
what i what
we were talking earlier about not hiding
things in the fog
this is part of the process of coming to
a clearer vision of yourself is noticing
exactly that because your theory was
well i can buy this cryptocurrency
and maybe i'll make some money but
regardless one way or another
this is going to make my life better you
had a theory of yourself and you had a
theory of the money
ah yeah well it turns out that that was
wrong now why
exactly we don't know but the
consequence of that was that you became
a slave to a set of impulses that you
didn't find enjoyable in the least
yeah and that is and so then you stop
doing it and and
and and fair enough that seems to be the
right right solution
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one